[Musique]
pour se rendre à montréal sophie passe
par la ville de longueuil
soudain elle s'aperçoit que sa voiture
fait de la fumée elle appelle le 9 1 les
pompiers arrivent en grande pompe la
fumée a déjà disparu mais les pompiers
examine la voiture pour s'assurer qu'il
n'y a pas de danger
sophie apprendra ensuite que la fumée a
été causé par un problème dans le
circuit électrique
huit mois plus tard cette histoire est
oublié lorsqu'elle reçoit une lettre de
la ville de longueuil elle louvre et
manque de s'évanouir
la ville lui réclame 5750 dollars comme
sophie n'est pas résidente de longueuil
la ville a le droit de lui faire payer
les vrais pour le déplacement des
pompiers et longueuil et gourmand car
pour la même intervention auprès de non
résidentes montréal aurait réclamé 655
dollars presque dix fois moins
heureusement les assurances auto ouvre
toujours ses frères ayew le fin mot de
l'histoire
vous avez besoin des pompiers dans une
autre ville que la vôtre il n'y a pas le
feu
votre assurance auto va payer